okay so this is love games oh not nearly
as sexy as it sounds get the fuck away
from me
but it is an episode that has been
addressing a little bit more is love and
loss so to say mostly just lost not as
much love but at least I'm not just
dropping it like nothing you know got
that that was the one thing it's like
even though it was kind of funny how at
the end of episode she's like yeah we're
broken up okay you know it's kind of
funny but I like that some of the stuff
with Flame Princess is still like with
them it still has like a little remorse
a you know it didn't work out and stuff
so he is he doesn't wanna think about
love anymore he wants to go and say
princesses again he does a lot datum but
then slide princess comes along with a
special mission she needs him to marry
her or else her his sister who just got
married is going to take over the world
with this evil guy who according to
their plan like the slime people must be
like the most powerful people in the
world or whatever it's a superpower they
have the only three Cray rated it it's
so hot the tree trunks and mr. pig are
there which remind me bring us Emma but
I thought tree trunks for a sec I
thought actually maybe tree trunks but
was gonna be the husband because they
were about to sink our in the same size
I thought they were just gonna put like
Oh fun that's like I thought that was
gonna be the husband like just a
mustache on her but but I was wrong said
that that was my one guess banner he was
dead and that's just a big glob of glob
so why are you thinking about tree
trunks but cuz that's what it looked
like okay tree trunks is a very sexy
elephant okay I can't help it if
everywhere I look I see tree trunks is
about this hello why can't we talk about
tree trunks is anus you know it's sexy
stop throwing your
laughing Jory voice at me hey you wanna
come back we're gonna talk about that
still I can ignore it for a bit even
though you look like tree trunks ah nose
you look like tree trunks his nose not
her sexy around succulent piece of tail
here what did he say again
that's gross yeah that was like wow
this is just proof that Adventure Time
has some of the greatest timing of any
TV yeah that's you win this veto pen
okay okay so uh yesa go and marry her
and has to prove that they're in love so
what the prime know what wasn't Pope
both wine guy was it again with a grande
plop okay yeah Graham flop who was the I
think it was grant plop yeah who's the
Mac guy you know that I'm I'm a Mac and
I'm a PC
he's Mac he's doing the voice no he was
not use no news PC oh you're obviously
cool hip guy that's right I don't by the
way is not in Adventure Time
suck it Mac yeah that's true that
immediately makes PC cooler which is
fine by me because I have the PC Oh God
we're gonna get flooded with I know Mac
is technically better but well it's not
it's okay when you learn how to use it
when you put up with all the our club
only bullshit I know it's actually
better no it's not but but I hate that
our club only bullshit
so okay anyway we're getting way off
subject so yeah so you got the so they
had to convince everybody that they love
each other and stuff and then they find
out that the husband is not a husband
it's just a big Qantas wine right I mean
do they ever say exactly what it is no
what was it jello other Jason sorry boy
brain farted and when my brain fart
sounds like Jory no and they never say
what it is okay I I naturally want to
look over there well because normally
Georgia see the song that Finn's sings
to Flame Princess is what I think about
when I think of Jory yeah
why can't take it over her I miss her so
much
yeah I hear you can see doing her laugh
is obvious but I'm still is good for
women preferably of a thing combination
with princess princess slime princess
cookie princess not cookie okay I'm
probably just in the middle of the night
just kind of break off chunks and start
eating okay fair enough
can't see me like hot dog princess it's
one like toss her into the microwave
then you know so like if this right I
messed up for talking about tree trunks
succulent so anyway the the it's a fun
episode it's fine it's almost a
standalone one the only thing that sort
of separates it from being a standalone
is that he broke up with Flame Princess
or she broke up with him and Ice King
and Ice King was there in the opening to
offering to to help her out and marry
her which almost wouldn't be a bad plan
except that he's insane but I mean
there's just clearly a guy who'd be
totally fine with it
um but yeah he was a nice whole song
it's nicely could that kid sing a gallon
think we haven't heard him sing a song
in a while uh yeah actually I I want to
say it was kind of like a full set of
voice where I'm not super musical but if
I was
tonight it was actually like because
this voice is obviously mid change and
um to still be able to sing and have a
nice sounding voice it's not bad is that
you're pretty good I agree
so yes I like they're still kind of
keeping that going usually I don't like
it when somebody breaks up and it's like
oh they're gonna keep thinking about
that character come on just get them
back together or cut it off or do
something new but you know I but I like
those two characters together so I
wouldn't it's I'm cool with it for now I
just don't want to drag on forever
but ya know I did I thought was that
that was fun if that was good stuff yeah
I wasn't that impressed to be perfectly
honest it was okay there was some funny
scenes I did like when slime princess
was like wrap those giant pythons around
me that was funny
I did like this song other than that it
was kind of like like from the get-go it
was kind of the whole going back to
candy streets where as P so like this
first time I saw the America Mara
I can never say it oh let me say it
again Guillermo um when I saw him first
like I kind of knew already what was
going on and it was like oh that kind of
sucks it out and again maybe it was
intentional maybe it wasn't but I still
didn't like it mm-hmm
it was it okay yup so what I just I
don't like tree trunks since you ruined
the one you're just jealous of her ass
apparently I am and I'm okay with that
the you know the other thing I'll say
that and not like the greatest design
but I still thought pretty inventive the
whole slime Kingdom whatever and stuff I
thought looked you know I thought was
creative enough you know it wasn't
something like wow look at that but at
the same time it's like other stuff
about the shapes and the colors of like
that one building and the the whatever
the disco yeah and stuff like that you
know um and I sort of like the way
everybody sort of had this you know
everything was very grand but what they
would say was more like you know our
disco is rated 3 whatever was crazy 3
craze and stuff units I like they were
sort of talk with this weight but they'd
say
very you know like patent Juvenal yeah
you know by far the greatest looking one
in the room and see you know so I
thought that was kind of fun um I did
like when uh bla bla ballina no bubble
inna whatever the sister
blargh aleena blog de lima no oh let's
stop myself no but when she's sitting
there and she demands the like the
battle and slime princess is like no are
self-indulgent Society is beyond that
I'm like yeah that's kind of pretty much
that way yeah yeah like I like those
kind of lines like that yeah but you
have to try thing there's not there's
not much now the reason why your problem
with there my problem is with your whole
obsession with tree trunks and mine is
okay it's because he seems I'm talking
about eating our food you're talking
about a sexy elephant clearly you've
never eaten elephant you're not eating
our whoa are you going to be eating an
elephant depends what you mean by
exactly my point
so where's the difference then except
for the fact that my food elephant can
be food in your head good succulent um
no you know what I gotta say to that
what you fail dude yeah give me bin back
well but do you fin we stepped timing
good comedic timing God always works
with you
ah why are you hurting me you're just
jealous
have him close this up
Oh see super good
that works